hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Shadows overloathing if
you remember west of loathing this is
the sequel to that game and there was
another sequel that west of loathing is
a sequel to another game with Loathing
in the title that I can't exactly
remember what it was like it's spittoon
it's a spittoon that should bring enough
Bells if you don't know west of loathing
you you should know spittoon oh no
no this is a spittoon right tell me that
you know spittoon
please tell me you understand what
spatoon means
it's another Splatoon I don't think
there's going to be any spittoons in
this game but it should prove to be just
a fun adventure as west of loathing was
which was a very fun adventure
oh I'm in the game hello
you can't see anything interesting in
that direction actually you can't see
anything at all with this magazine stuff
to your face oh I suppose I do well
God I shouldn't I shouldn't give it the
benefit of the doubt with the Laughing
this early because I feel like there
should be more you hear the sounds of a
diner behind you maybe someone there can
help you with your little magazine on
the face problem or I could give up
well I guess what was I really expecting
oh fascinating all right I guess I gotta
go in the diner hello this smells like a
diner and it smells like they're open
hopefully they have a no shirt no shoes
magazine stuck to your face no service
sign posted hopefully they don't oh they
might just
the Nightingale welcomes all travelers
hi try coffee you'll like it eventually
restroom
something tells me I shouldn't go to the
restroom it's a bathroom probably you
blunder your way into the bathroom and
eventually find the sink after fumbling
with the faucet for a while you managed
to disintegle yourself from the magazine
you stare into the mirror revealing wow
was that right
how was I oh my oh
wow
oh no no I'm basic if you know me you
know that I don't really customize in
games and I don't feel the need to hear
this face got me through all of West of
loathing
and it got me through comfortably with
the confidence of everyone looking at my
face on understanding who I was so I'm
gonna go baby-faced and fresh-faced
there I am
oh sweet I got me
and I got bag and I got cogwheel
Grady the ren each round of combat
increase your muscle mystical or Moxie
by one everything you own is in a trunk
including your portable carpet steamer
unpacking into Diner seems like a bad
idea
what if I want to anyway
fine some RPG this is I don't even have
choices a couple of older folks are
having an animated discussion while one
of them is mind if I eavesdrop the way
these young women act these days with
their short hair and their sassy talk in
their dresses that don't even cover
their their ankles it's scandalous and
those dances they do flailing around
like I don't know what out of thought
prohibition would have put the kibosh on
that sort of Tom Foolery no sir but no
sir can't imagine dancing in Waltz to
the music they're playing nowadays
though and that's a problem right there
this newfangled jazz music with all the
drums and clarinets and such what kind
of word is that anyway Jazz I think our
cups got switched they're supposed to be
drinking decaf yeah I suppose so some
petty vandals scratched the name Dan Bob
into the surface of the stable
interesting this man is concentrating
very hard on his coffee
hey there is there something
particularly interesting about that cup
of coffee it's my first one of the day
no it's my first copy ever oh what do
you think I think it's a bad beverage
it's bitter and it makes my stomach hurt
oh well it's not for everybody I suppose
yeah I think I'll have another one of
this uh after this though and then maybe
every morning for the rest of my life
yeah that is Hobby well enjoy hi I'm
Ethel I'm
I'm kenberto I'm Leonard I'm Nathaniel
um
as much as I would love to be Ken Berto
which is a great name I guess I'll
mark
God seems so boring why couldn't that
the name convertible
[Music]
I'm Mark Mark who Mark Collins Cooper
thumbs
Mark thorms ah no that's dumb eplier
pleased to be you Marky plier can what
can I get you
um
does the bus to Ocean City pick up here
I get coffee sure best cup of coffee in
the state if I say so myself that'll be
one meat oh I forgot meat was the
currency
I forgot about that much like orc with
teeth I'm broke
oh this is the bus pick up should I
should be here any minute good thing too
I hear we're in for rain tonight what
takes you to Ocean City my uncle lives
there I got a letter from him he wants
me to help him with something that's a
reason hon but it's somebody else's
reason what's your reason Ethel locks
eyes with you
mind your own business Ethel
you got perk guarded oh your hard
exterior conceals what I can only assume
is an even harder interior oh iron
within iron without am I right of course
on where are my manners I'm sorry to pry
my curiosity just got the best of me
[Laughter]
frowning can't you
can't you tell everybody over here
a couple of young women are chatting
breezily over coffee hey Mac what's this
what town is this
who keeps he who keepsey are you two
traveling yeah ocean City's turning into
a real Sawmill so we boosted your jelly
beans Breezer for a weekend world of La
potato oh Bush well you make it sound
like we went South with it I flew him a
kite everything is Jake what
what geez I'm pretty sure I'm only three
or four years older than you two but I
barely understand what you're saying
what are you canceled stamp go put some
pepper in your shoes
okay I'll try that okay I got new what
do I have new ah I'm guarded which I
find to be pretty good
I forgot that I have to do some sort of
combat eventually oh they got one of
these new Mead operated multi-selection
photographs for jukeboxes as the kids
call them neat hey there's something in
the corner turn
coffee coffee
hello I'm gonna get a cup of coffee one
meat please ah Ethel porzi is steaming
hot cup of fresh black Java okay good
anything else nope I'm good thank you
what do I do with it do I drink it good
grief this coffee smells good you can't
bring yourself to drink it because you
really need you might really need some
coffee later
I guess I might really need some coffee
later
okay cool I'm down for prologue
that is some thick black rain outside
did I just thrust that into existence
I guess it's not the only thing that's
been thrusted into existence pretty much
all of us were you pull out the letter
you got from Uncle Murray and read it
Murray Morris Murray's antiques dear
Mark I hope this letter finds you well
and I hope it finds you quickly
something serious has happened and I
need your help I need the help of your
adventuresome spirit come to my shop in
Ocean City as soon as you're able to
your Uncle Murray thanks I'm sleeping
and there's a clown
I hope that's a clone
earlier
you're just about to go mad from the
monotony of this ride when the bus
suddenly jutters to a stop you look out
the window expecting to see sights and
sounds of Ocean City but instead you see
an endless expanse of extremely wet
trees oh
oh
drink red Cola Cola probably should ask
you should probably you should ask the
bus driver what's going on instead of
just wandering off aimlessly Into the
Night no why would drinking red Cola
protect my family
Veiled Threat
I like thinly veiled threats I did
enforce a policy recently you may not
have heard of it but all comments and
chat in my channel must be made in the
form of a thinly Veiled Threat
so get to that in the comments what's
going on this doesn't look like Ocean
City nope sorry about this but we're out
of gas oh geez didn't you fill up I
filled up the bus but this trip takes
exactly one full tank of gas
plus one additional can okay
sure why do I have to go get it well I
go myself for two reasons I was being
firstly being as I'm the bus driver I'm
legally responsible for this bus and I
gotta keep an eye on it and secondly
because of my leg what's wrong with your
leg it's attached to a fella that
doesn't want to go wandering around in
the rain tonight
I'm sure you can come up with some
thinly veiled threats well
it shouldn't take me this long to come
up with a thinly veiled thread now the
pressure's on it better be good if I had
all this time to think about it well you
you bet you better you better hope your
other leg
doesn't
cause you Rob
my legs are attached to someone that's
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you got him
huh well all right then guess I haven't
got much of a choice can I borrow your
umbrella it's a left-handed umbrella
I'm not
nuts sorry about that here I do have a
right-handed flashlight
God I wish I was left-handed oh man why
is it gotta be like this why does it got
to be like this coffee
oh I might really need it later all
right goodbye you wouldn't make it dog
walk six miles in this rain no matter
how bad it wanted to well I'm not a dog
put this bus lacks in Comfort it makes
up for an unreliability I love this game
oh
all right now with extra lead dude you
tell me oh hell yeah oh
this don't look good either they're out
of postcards or all the scenery around
here is invisible it's one object left I
got a cheese loaf nobody in the right
mind would consider this vile substance
a snack
am I in my right mind I don't know
huh yum
cured by the absence of crackers you eat
the cheese loaf with your bare hands in
the end you are unclean both inside and
out I got improved loafing
all right
cool
it's weird that the cash register is
pointed towards the front of the store
mine ooh that's a meat in there
hope that's good baseball bat nice this
is Cola oil cans no
well the sign says employee only are you
an employee
I mean not really
well since the place is out of business
it probably wouldn't hurt for you to go
back there I guess well thank you
well thank you that's very nice it's a
broken radio can still be considered
nice as a pretty nice radio
desk uh four doors contain nothing but
old receipts fifth one is locked
interesting axle Grease
oh
hello weird machine I don't have any
mysticality
control lifts stand clear of lift before
operating Steve okay big pool chest
already stolen fuse box has advertised
as a box containing one fuse however the
fuse is broken which is probably not
intended you should keep an eye for a
replacement it must be somewhere around
here well I guess probably on this shelf
of weirdos things a fuse
come on
I got a fuse
oh this is easy this is really easy so
easy I should probably save how do I
save again I don't even remember
that can't be done uh reviews okay I
probably needed to do that before I did
this
weird machinist and I'll
installity
can I get some quick wit I really need
some quick wit right about now pour it
in your can there's a big glass that's a
big glass
that's what I get for reading that one
backwards
convenient ah okay well is that is that
not gonna do it for me I need more I
thought that would have been it man I
was so ready
all right
Finnegan's optional boxing gym you don't
have to fight if you don't want to
oh that's so nice I'm glad I don't have
to be pressured
because I know it's not compulsory yeah
oh hi um hello a miserable looking
hitchhiker is standing in the rain this
leaves sticking out her thumb hi there
her head turns very slowly and her eyes
don't quite meet yours can you give me a
lift I need to get to Albany sorry I'm
going the other way oh also I don't have
a car oh
what's your name I'm Mark Lydia nice to
meet you Lydia although I admit the
circumstances aren't great
uh how about this how about this rain
huh oh it's good rain
Lydia looks very slightly surprised and
glances around slowly oh it's raining
yeah sure is what a night to be stuck
out on the road right I'm honest I get
the feeling you aren't much of a noticer
well anyway
what's a nominee family nah I just want
to go somewhere new how many isn't new
though it's one of the oldest cities in
the country
hahaha
all right
um
do you read any books
I read the Invisible Man it was really
good oh H.G Wells is great have you read
this new one the war in the air I didn't
care for it the one I'm thinking of is
Mr something on something Island I
forget the name his early works are best
like the time machine I love that one
I'm glad we were able to find something
we could connect on
um
any good movies
Dr Jekyll nicholin of Dr Jekyll
mickelheide Mr Hyde at the Nickelodeon
oh classic very scary have you seen the
cameraman Sherlock Jr
all right I know where I can get some
gas the bus I was uh on ran out the
driver sent me this fine one bus trying
to get to Ocean City never been there
all right
um
um
[Music]
okay bye good luck this field is
extremely corny yeah
hey uh I want to be unfriendly but this
is a private residence you just barged
into oh geez sorry everything's so
desolate outside I just assumed it was
abandoned well come morning you'll be
right so you might as well get out of
the rain
for his Bell huh
thanks I'm Marky blier I'm Elias make
yourself at home
gears tears and bear beer beer is that
beers you got beers over there this is
beers
uh what's with the beers oh no they're
canned pears I had a little fun riding
the labels is all you want a can thanks
mysticality I need that what's uh what's
this weird thing it's a duck call what's
it for it's for calling Ducks well fun
used to be don't work anymore on the
count of being haunted
what uh not haunted exactly a bunch of
spiders got in there now it sounds all
scary when you blow it
see if you want it's yours you take you
generally take the duck Ultron very hard
not to think about spiders
make it
did yes what spiders
what's oh what spiders good job oh
thanks uh
can I
reduces in enemy's Miss muscle
mysticality amoxy when you honk at them
well I'm glad I have that equipped uh
what about the gears my daughter Simone
left those when she went off to school
figured that I should keep them for
that makes sense
tears are these boxes of Tears or tares
don't be ridiculous you can't put
neither of them in a box that don't make
any kind of sense yeah you're right
you're right about oh
I didn't mean to go out back wait let me
back in let me back in good God I'm not
ready for that can I use your bathroom
sure how do you know that door was a
bathroom though I was at an act for
knowing which doors lead to bathrooms is
all well good for you I guess
oh thanks
you flush chekhov's toilet hoping it
won't come back to haunt you later why
would it
why would why would that come back to
haunt me
tell me why that would come back to
haunt me why why would that come back to
haunt me
okay whatever I'm gonna gaze into the
mirror hi Mark
hey there good looking oh what's wrong
oh no oh no
you remember something really
embarrassing you did a couple years ago
oh
I'll just assume this looks good
ah there you are hey they're good
looking oh this is great I wonder if
that change does that change my
expression like as I'm going around
hope
oh
no I gotta go back to normal who's
smiling here
there we go good stuff let me check out
what the uh this one leads to
where's this door lead to spare bedroom
main used it in forever I don't even
bother opening the door since the dust
devil got in there feel free to help
yourself though I doubt you'll find much
use
messed up yeah those Critter is a real
nuisance around here they're attracted
to beds that ain't been cleaned properly
and since I lost my broom back in 26
it's been a real what's the moon call it
a new tree in a rich environment ornery
little beast real territorial
hmm interesting
ah
shout out shootout at all all owl Arroyo
oh
a trail at Six Gun Creek Duel at horse
thief Trail Riders of the West oh the
handguns tail
oh that's pretty good I'll read that
wow oh
pretty boring I don't have
no
reality
where's my mysticality meat alright mine
now I guess dust Devil's really kicking
up some Dickens under there all right
you kick up my Dickens are you sure
Chekhov said these things are pretty
dangerous yeah I'm sure oh God
oh
ow why oh God
I'm gonna honk at you you better watch
it oh God I'm gonna die I'm gonna honk
at you is what I got try not to think of
those spiders
I'm probably gonna die
yep
Wham oh I'm dead
ow well
I'm dead
should have listened to chica I guess so
you know you're right about that well
that was something but uh alas I did I
didn't make it can I talk to you all
right why are you leaving well my
daughter went off to college so there's
nothing keeping me here I never
particularly cared for a farming anyhow
just kind of fell into it you know so I
reckoned I dig the opportunity to retire
and travel a bit see what kind of
trouble I can get up to so what's your
story what do you do now like this I got
a letter from my Uncle Murray sounded
urgent so I hopped on a bus to Ocean
City I ain't sure how to tell you this
but you got a ways to go yet yeah the
bus ran out of gas to the driver sent me
the scavenge for some more I got you
well I think there's an old gas can in
the barn out back you're welcome to it I
gotta warn you though you'll have to
fight my daughter for it
but well technically I should say my
daughter's a monster my daughter's
monster huh it's a thing my daughter
Simone built
what see my kids are real technical whiz
she built an auto ominous Robo traction
to help with plowing and harvesting and
the like work real nice too the problem
is after she left it it blew a what's it
tube and got violent I'm pretty sure
good with Machinery when it comes down
to these newfangled electrics I might as
well be a dog try and read Play-Doh so I
locked the barn ah I see you're welcome
to try your hand against it if you mind
to but please be careful it's got a lot
of sharp bits on it ah that uh was this
a gun hanging out to dry nothing on the
clothesline except a pair of socks and
an old gun take the gun and leave the
socks they don't look
and you read about that probably
socks just keep getting wetter someone's
shooting over here hello
this scarecrow's a bit more
[Laughter]
this is scary scarecrow I'm not scared
of you though you better watch it
a shoot crew
God you intend to do how much damage to
me oh my God all right
honk take that that's what you get and
then I'm gonna thwack you
there we go
I've whacked you good don't shoot me ow
thanks bird using the skill costs an
action point you will your turn will not
end until you make a basic attack all
right take that
that was nice
ow man the gun really really does a
difference I hope this hits
all right game over Crow
there you go
[Music]
I did it I feel great about myself
I just remembered that I flushed the
toilet and it might come back to haunt
me why would it do that the old tractor
there's an old rack shoved in where the
gas cap should be pulled the rag out
sniff the tank smells like there's a
little gas in there
all right
dip the rag and soak it all up then ring
it out in my can I don't know if that's
the best one that tractor is the right
most interesting thing in this part of
the country
all right duly noted
you leave the doors open
leave the key in the lock in case he
wants to lock it up all right oh what's
nice in here I thought it'd be boss
fight immediately
I saw that
God I got no stats
oh
this must be the farmer's daughter's
fishing's Rod she won't miss it you
assume I got a fishing rod oh hell yeah
what do I do with that muscle plus one
is a fishing rod used for fishing and
definitely not for fighting well I'm too
stupid to understand what that means so
I'm a sh I'm gonna fight with that
fishing rod oh I'll test my fishing rod
I'm not sure how this works but it's
barely working
you didn't catch anything but it was
good practice
because you're right huh
you can glue through this machine for
turning hay bales is loose into loose
hay wait all right can I oh you're not
gonna get past this thing without
destroying it I'll destroy it then
maybe not with a I'll do it with a
fishing rod all right you're done for I
think
well you only have four all right you're
basically nothing I'm gonna honk at you
anyway
[Applause]
oh wow that works out pretty good ow
well
I guess this is all we need
take that
and that
was pretty good you got enough XP now to
learn a skill open the character sheet
via the icon to the right or hit C rest
in Parts uh workbench for welding search
it
mostly tools you don't understand but
you do find some gloves
I got hot armor gas
you go up there if it weren't for your
hay fever and you're falling out of lost
fever
I thought I could level up
can't I
oh I can okay I could level up Moxie and
wrench open this thing
but I kind of have a habit of going for
strength in games oh wait Moxie isn't
strength wait is it muscle muscle ah
that would have been a mistake well I
don't have enough to get mercile and I
don't think I have any food that could
boost my muscle
what is woo this option is haunt
Ed
[Laughter]
how long is it there Arachnophobia
arachnophilia you will encounter so many
spiders I guess I should have quit this
it is Moxie based and I am moxied right
now
fine maybe I could kill that devil now
yeah I did I did the thing scarecrow I
had to beat up your scarecrow sorry I
was leaving it behind anyhow why'd you
go and do a thing like that for it shot
at me with a gun oh right yeah it's
perfectly reasonable then uh uh that's
right
let's see what happens
ah the vicious stabbing kind of Hoyts
that it really oats I don't even know if
it's gonna do anything I could try to
take that
and that
oh
[Music]
and I'm dead Okay so that don't work
even though I oh the hot damage
[Music]
gloves I have them quipped it doesn't
matter all right so I'm just not ready
for that well I got the gas I guess I
get out of here unless oh hey buddy oh
no I am I am helping it oh there you go
buddy oh enjoy blue Cola The Honorable
Choice an old billboard from before the
war where you going buddy
would you go back behind the house buddy
did you go behind the house buddy I
thought I saw him go behind the house
oh
nothing else except sit on it and
pretend to be a farmer
yeah I'll do that I hope I have time to
reap some some Molina before it's time
to milk the donkeys keep pretend gotta
milk the steers before sunup uh plant
the spelled and then rake the Spells
time to dust my Millet man even
pretending to farm his artwork oh no I
haven't played the Bulls no I meant to
say I have to share them or walk the
chicken there's some Molina fertilize
some Fields
um
plow my sorghum
goats all right goodbye
well I got some XP which is just more
than I thought would have been in this
occurrence well thanks so much for
whatever the hell you did for me which
was apparently everything God for being
a stranger everything's fine what's this
oh that's Simone's room hopefully she
ain't left anything important there
because I Plum forgot how to work that
crazy lock
well
I guess I'm never gonna know
unless I can get through the wall hmm
what's that about hmm what's all this
about if only I had like a krober
[Music]
well anyway
what's over hey what in the hell is this
Topeka
foreign
[Applause]
hello
wait an open fire and enclosed space
classic hey there's something in there
give
evil
if only uh there it is
there it is I got a Grover hi
don't you hit me hi there I'm Howie
pleased to meet you well the way I see
it this whole country's my own so
everybody's my neighbor oh that's nice
either that or they're all trespasses
you better get off my property I'm
joking care for some jerky what kind
clam it's a local delicacy yeah awesome
I'll get clam jerky that's nice it's
always nice to give from a kindly
stranger but it's especially nice when
that gift is dried flesh yes it is where
are you from originally I'm from Hawaii
me too but I got bored of gorgeous
tropical beaches inside hit the rails
you rode the rails from Hawaii yep real
Challenge and trip for the first time
but I made it through all right you ever
gonna go back you only got one track
there so it's a one-way trip I might
head back for a visit once they've built
a second one though huh all right thank
you what's your in your bag oh that
ain't mine that's been here since before
I arrived myself no one's been able to
work out how to open it if you can
figure out the trick you're welcome to
it appears to be latched shut with one
of those puzzles made out of Ben nails
and steel wire oh wasn't just harmonic
and Dixie I'll leave it alone for now
hey gas
I already have gas
I've got a
you put signs of garbage 133 full can
wow shiny
whoa and make everyone think you
attended sit or mugged someone that did
I love that the seaside Institute of
Technology
my favorite well
well could do well let me let me before
I do that let me go left and see if
there's anything else
heard a lot of nice things about Topeka
but it's not 1 200 miles worth of nice
things let me go see because I believe
that that floorboard is screaming for
this crowbar that I have
crowbar some kind of seller here
ah interesting
decades-old bacon grease interesting
make a crude ladder oh
I did that
there's a food are revolting but on the
bright side all but three of them are
broken I'll take the unbroken ones thank
you hey what's up spiders you can't tell
if these spiders are fighting or
flirting
well I got a fishing rod
so we'll find out no
well I'm poisoned
ow
well that's hardly nice okay so you
don't have a lot of Health
but it would have been a lot better if I
could have actually
[Music]
killed you
take that and one of these
that's not quite enough
I'm really poisoned
oh don't do it ah
ah yes
shrug oh
well
I have somewhere south of two spiders
worth of fighting me I you know you're
kind of shut up
yeah I can't fight those guys
oh
I have that kind of muscle but I could
have that kind of muscle
do I really want this to be my skill
though if I have this plus one more
muscle
I could technically
I could technically open that other
thing too I'm gonna eat this I know I'm
getting rid of my moxie
I don't think I'm gonna need it for
anything else was it my oh this needed
three Moxie this might be the last thing
that needs Moxie so if I technically
leveled up with this then switched and
ate the clam jerky I might be fine I
might be okay
let's go moxie
yeah let's do it
nice so I should be able to open this
now
[Music]
I remember there was something locked I
remember I remember so I'm gonna keep my
Moxie for now I'm gonna switch to muscle
eventually and then hopefully I get
enough experience to level up again and
do muss of what we have plaque where
Lydia was standing historic site at this
exact spot on the 13th of October 1908
the state's first mass-produced
automobile a Ford Model T purchased by
hiramo crawlins accidentally struck and
killed the state's first hitchhiker
Lydia Barnsley
so apparently that woman you talked to a
few minutes ago has been dead for
exactly 20 years good swell everything
about this is great and you aren't
regretting this trip
[Music]
wasn't there a desk here
oh gas pump hose
whoa little silver key falls into the
hole and the floor and disappears all
right I got gas pump O's though maybe
I'll use it for the gas pumps
oh
oh
full of water inside
I don't know can I
you should have known there weren't any
fish in there you can see in the entire
thing
oh look at those
well I got even more gas now so
technically I could go
but I'm not gonna so that was all that
was over there
combat oh I found a ring found this old
class ring hey a 17 sit I've got one of
these in faux Emerald with benafo
sapphire these are the ones they gave to
junior varsity big skinners had a little
enchantment on them so the kids wouldn't
get quite so many concussions is it
worth anything not a jeweler could give
you 30 meat let me think about it
because what would this give me what
does it give me it doesn't give me
anything
should I sell it
what if it's important I haven't seen
anything yet that needs
money
and if it's got an enchantment on them
what if someone knows that I went to sit
all right I think I'm gonna switch it
over I'm gonna eat the clam jerky
yeah I don't need the loafing okay
opening
that was an extremely heavy door ah
what in the world is that there's a
carving on the trunk it says Howie loves
playing the harmonica oh
oh
placed a sheet of filthy linoleum in an
effort to lend legitimacy to this
outdoor kitchen ah stew is beyond
salvaging all right I'll get the label
Ladle no wonder the Stew's so messed up
it's not a ladle it's a spatula all
right
I mean that's magical how I'm not gonna
ask any questions I I don't even know
about that open Mason Jar full of cats
oh
good anyway I'm gonna fight you uh-oh
it's a railroad bull although railroad
Minotaur would probably be more accurate
imma fight you
get ready to get honked
honk take this
that's what you get
yeah
oh God no please oh that was hardly
anything take that
well this would be easy yeah
easy
[Music]
greedy the ren grows stronger I didn't
even know Grady was in trouble
what is this nine uh 19 1911 Ford milk
crate for wheels that model never really
seemed to take off I'll guess I have so
much gas now
why do I have so much gas I did it
uh I dealt with the railroad bull for
you you did that's a real service to the
hobo Community I ain't got nothing to
offer you as a reward but I surely won't
forget this okay but thank you okay so I
did everything I needed to there
I technically don't have enough muscle
to go up I don't have enough XP unless I
were to try to kill either the devil or
the spiders I guess I could try to kill
the spiders again there might be a way
there might be a way if I were to be
able if I was able to kill one of them
if they if they didn't poison me right
away that's the problem right they
poison me right away
ow and then I don't have any other turn
but if I were if this ah I feel like
that should do more damage
I should have attacked him when I had
more moxie
I should have done the gun with more
Moxie and that might have been able if I
had three Moxie at the time it probably
would have been able to kill them in one
hit but as it stands I just die
immediately because of that
and then I could be able to kill the
other one in one hit
hmm I think I goofed it but there might
be a way for me to kill the the Dirt
Devil here maybe
[Music]
ow that hurt a lot it's got 10 HP though
[Applause]
if only I had just like a little if I
don't if I only didn't switch out my
Moxie it would have been fine there's
got to be something else I can I can
attack or kill or something like that
oh even here I'm like close but I didn't
get it
for oh if only I had done another perk
oh man I bet I bet there's another perk
that would like get
Moxie or something like that oh boy the
turtle oh Turtle seems to be heading to
oh it might be there
what do you want to name
her
heart hurt
the turtle
oh who heals me
well there's something there maybe
that's all the difference I needed maybe
that's exactly what I was hoping for hey
will this make any difference
ow
oh
there's no one injured well there was
about to be
Bert please
okay I wonder
ow
that's blood I'm dead but that was plus
one that was plus one
pretty
pretty okay I know I have these these
items here these gross vegetables right
so technically speaking I can use one of
them but I'm not sure if I can actually
win so with four bleeding
I go down to six
if I throw this it reduces
there his muscle by one probably would
do like two damage
I'm down to six I get healed one hit two
I go down to five
or uh I go to six if he reduces his
Damage Done by two I go down to five I
only have three rounds to do damage I it
might work it it might work
because I have four bleeding right now
and I'm not damaged so
what I need to do is if I throw this
doesn't take AP I heave this at you
one damage okay
[Music]
this could work
no I only get two turns oh I still need
the extra thing of mysticality because I
don't have ah because that takes it down
to two and this takes it down by two to
six because I'll survive this
but I won't survive the next one
right God damn it
oh man okay the only way I can win kind
of also removes the ability for me to do
anything later uh because it would be
gone anyway but at this point I don't
really care I'm gonna I'm gonna do this
I shouldn't have juggled the food like
this but what it does do is because this
is a better weapon I equip that this
should allow me to kill it if I do
enough damage to kill it in two turns
which I should because this will do
three damage so I heave this
I throw this
I flip this yeah
and then wouldn't you know it
wham bam
I'm alive you're gonna be dead in the
next one because I flipped the eye I do
that and then I'm gonna flip you flip
done I win
shockingly I win and that's enough to
get me another level I'll do mysticality
because I can't get muscle anymore to
get the three to open the thing but
there was still one more thing to open
the three so I'm doing mysticality
yes
so let's go open the other thing and
then maybe try to take the spiders but I
don't think I can win against the
spiders no matter what
hey
that's pretty good I'm doing I know you
don't care because you're like where's
the laughs okay hellco portable gasoline
it's a machine for generating portable
gasoline
well
I got even more gasoline I don't even
know what was the point of having 266
gasoline I'm gonna go I'm gonna go see
if I can beat the spiders I don't think
I can but I could kill him in one go
I could kill one of them in one turn
anyway yeah I think so
ow so I do that and then I go four
damages are pretty good
so long as you don't
super poison me
and you're dead sure seems like a gun
spatula but whatever
I've
I think I still should survive this oh
just barely
you're done now
you're done flip good flip wow flipped
into forever
okay well I did that I don't know why I
did that but I did that a little extra
XP I guess all right thank you very much
I did it I killed the dust devil well
thank you of course a bit late for my
purposes but I imagine the next
occupants will be grateful it was a snap
I think I just have this ring and I kind
of want to hold on to it because I'm
greedy like that
and I can't open that door anyway
because it's locked so I guess I'm done
here I guess I just take my ass over to
the bus give off the 266 gas
I don't know why I imagine there's got
to be like one more gas that's probably
in that cabinet that I would have needed
to unlock with the muscle but I juggled
it wrong and yeah it happens it happens
all right hey bud I got your gas
hey my guess again what this can doesn't
usually hold that much gas not sure how
you did it but whatever you ready to hit
the road yeah I guess let's get out of
here I'm sure there's something I missed
but it's too late
all right you climb back on the bus and
return to your seat and soon you're
dozing off to the sound of rain
spattering on the window beside you
unfortunately it's barely in a
barroximation of sleep the sort of sleep
you slip into so gradually you don't
even know you're asleep until something
wakes you up
long history and you realize that you're
Meandering thoughts of the past few
minutes have been utterly strange Shadow
shadowy Trend drills of whispering ideas
Hey kid this is your stop right that are
now totally forgotten
all ashore what's going ashore thanks
for traveling wil's butt cool but Busco
Cola Wars Surplus what
oh
what Cola Wars I like your hat
nice weather he smiles looks up and lets
the rain splash his face excuse me just
fine A wise man once said the rain falls
on poor and rich men alike was that
before umbrellas were invented my name's
Gus by the way I'm Mark pleased to meet
you hey you wouldn't happen to have a
couple of meat to spare would you I
gotcha don't worry Gus old Gus won't
forget about your kindness you bet take
your easy Gus all right well we made it
to the town what's in cold Wars it's
closed for the night oh Maurice antiques
but
oh she cloned my stench armor
I don't know what that means
well anyway we're about to enter
Murray's antiques because that's the
next stage but that'll have to wait
until the next episode thank you all so
much for watching I can't wait to get
into Shadows of loathing made me laugh a
lot already and I'm sure there are more
laughs in store so thank you and as
always
see you
bye-bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]